what would happen over and over again is
people would tell me things and I'd be
like Have you shared this with anyone
well I've said like a little to my
spouse but like I can't talk about this
with anyone so I was like oh wow what
I'm writing about is like this hidden
knowledge that nobody feels they can
talk about publicly Paul has written a
fantastic book called the pathless puff
of which I have about 10 copies here in
the office because I give copies to
anyone who is struggling to figure out
what they want to do with their lives I
went out for a motorcycle ride the ideas
just came to me and I just broke down in
tears I realized it had like everything
to do with my parents they didn't go to
college they had to do the default path
and I realized what they gave me was the
freedom to dream it matters to like
dream do Brave things I really think
this matters and I think I can help
people with this stuff and I'm just
gonna say it Paul has a super
interesting background he used to work
in a traditional field in management
consulting but then he quit his job to
kind of wander this pathless path and he
writes a lot around how do we think of
what a career means as soon as I left my
job I saw sort of dealt with this jolt
of reality of like this increased
freedom and space in my life and then in
2020 the whole world sort of like showed
up like asking these deep questions
about work and my readership just like
exploded the old formulas of what led to
career and like life success and
fulfillment and stuff like you know just
get a job and work your way up at the
company and get the company car and all
that kind of stuff that's not really the
formula that works anymore I think
Paul's ways of thinking about this are
incredibly inspiring so if you've ever
thought you're not really sure what you
want to do with your life if you've ever
had a doubts about are you really in the
right sort of career I really hope
you'll get a lot of value from this
conversation just a very quick thing
before we get started if you have not
yet subscribed to the podcast either on
YouTube or in your favorite podcast app
of choice then please do it really helps
us out a lot so Paul welcome welcome to
the show thank you so much for coming on
how are you doing
I am excited to be back talking with you
I think we talked almost like two years
ago at this point the first time so
excited to dive in and catch up on both
our Journeys yeah that would be sick um
so I've been every every time I have a
bit of a crisis in my life trying to
figure out what I want to do I always
think of you and I would think of your
writing and your book and your uh your
newsletter
um so it's all just like I mean you're
sort of my
um
I don't know my my life path pathless
path Guru um even though I'm sure you
don't intend to to be as such I would
love to get started with if you can just
uh how do essentially like how how did
we get here um how did you and I ended
up and end up talking like this how did
you end up developing this I guess
career that that you've landed into
yeah so so we'll have to dive into the
what we're talking about when we say
words like career but
um my path grew up in a small town in
Connecticut
um sort of uh always did good in school
stumbled into all these really
impressive career options in college
tried to break into them ended up
breaking into strategy Consulting for
like nine years loved my time working in
that industry but sort of
ended up feeling more and more stuck the
longer I spent on that path and really
just desired to escape so I saved it
it's not that large amount of money and
enough to kind of buy freedom for a year
wanted to run away from work and on that
Journey which has been
five years at this point sort of
discovered I didn't want to escape work
I wanted to have a different
relationship with work I basically
wanted like things I could connect to
work that brought me alive things that
energized me
um but it was really a slow stumbling uh
Awakening to that and a lot of my
writing was about that I think that was
some of the writing you connected with
and increasingly in 2020 a lot of the
world started paying attention to what I
was writing about
um before that I was kind of I didn't
really know if what I was writing about
was connecting with people but in 2020
just so many people started showing up
and reaching out and starting uh talking
to me so that's a that's a pretty cool
journey of you know starting out with a
very very traditional career I guess and
then deciding to break away from it and
and do your thing
um
I cut so
for for a podcast like this it's like
there's
I think this there's sort of two ways to
go about it one way is is where I
essentially act as an interviewer and
ask you your story because I know that
um I I imagine most people listening to
this are not familiar with your story
but I feel like because I'm already
familiar with it that bit is less
interesting to me and I just want to
dive in I think that's a possibility
just like just sort of diving into
um the the things that I am currently
struggling with and I would just love to
get your take on it to be my personal
therapist for this uh how does that
sound let's do it I mean this is the
Deep dive right so I love going deeper
anyway
my story's out there people can find it
they can get the the service level stuff
and I think the more interesting thing
is that when we look at what other
people do we tend to look at the surface
level stuff
um I was I was writing about this this
week and I sort of referenced you in a
post I was writing about which is like
just observing you you seem to have
found some sort of mode in which you're
able to show up in your life doing work
you actually like doing and we can dive
into whether that is still true or not
and to what degree
um but when people look at you they
probably look at like metrics right
metrics dollar amounts all these things
but
what I'm sort of talking about in a
relationship with work is like that
stuff is secondary
and convincing people that is that is
secondary is actually hard to do in
today's world because so much of the
world is oriented around the idea that
like these metrics these sort of goals
these titles are what matters if that's
secondary then then what is primary I
guess I think what I'm trying to say
with work is that
if we're just sort of showing up and
accepting what Society tells us I call
this like the default path the default
path is what most people around us are
doing this is the story we grow up with
in our culture that says you are
successful if you do these things get a
job go to school get good grades start a
family right
and for most people that works pretty
well but increasingly large amounts of
people one either can't make that work
or end up on that path and something is
just totally off
now I think part of the nature of work
and it becoming abstracted we're not
using our hands we're not literally
connecting to what we're doing anymore
people are just not as satisfied with
their work they're also taking these
ideas like meaningful work and trying to
fit it into a job container
and they're not quite getting what they
want and so there's this sort of
confusion and people don't really know
what to do with that feeling and I think
those feelings are really human ones of
like wanting to matter
wanting to be useful wanting to feel
connected to the world to people around
us to ourselves
and that those are the things I'm
arguing I think are worth finding
um
but they're non-trivial to find and
might require blowing up your life and
doing things that don't look like
success on paper
yeah yeah I think that's that's why this
gets kind of tricky because
you know just like just like you I've
had a very kind of traditional education
went into a job that was by all kind of
external metrics and stuff like a
prestigious and useful and good for
society thing to do and in a way when I
decided to leave medicine to become a
you know YouTuber for God's sake that
you know there was a huge part of me
that was like is this is this really
legit like yeah
um am I am I making the right decision
like will I essentially become a an
outcast or a pariah in society because I
have gone for this I've I've chosen to
leave something as Noble a profession as
medicine which saves lives for the sake
of making silly videos on the internet
um and so I think I think that's part of
it it's like the what does what what
will Society think of me but I think
also like I've had a bunch of
conversations with people since since I
announced my decision to leave medicine
and stuff people now stop emailing me
having career crises that are I'm in
this job and the job pays well but it's
not the thing I really want to do how
how do you think about it in terms of
like we'll we all need money to survive
right like so there is a baseline level
of money that we need to get in our jobs
and the legible alternative careers of
these days actually become a creator has
become a lot more legible than it used
to be back in the day become a Creator
is one of the things where there's
basically zero guarantee of making any
money at all at least for the first for
the first while especially if someone's
a complete beginner to it so how do you
how do you tackle that thing of I need
money to survive my job gives me money
but it's not the thing that I really
want to do
I think the thing to do is sort of
unpair the the stories the ship the
shoulds we all have these like shoulds I
should do this I should do that and like
really what I'm urging people to do is
like actually reconnect with what how
they're feeling
it sounds so easy but even with like the
Creator path becoming more legible more
and more people are coming to me and
saying oh I think I want to quit my job
and do my own thing
but then they'll list out a bunch of
like concerns and issues they'll have
and I'll have to be like no like based
on the people I know who are thriving in
this path you are not those people
so what do you mean
I think in the sense
I think in the sense that like they
aren't like valuing the freedom
of being on your own high enough they
aren't valuing they'll come to me with
like oh what if I can't make money what
if I don't have predictable income and
it's like you're not yet valuing the
upsides of such a path
like whereas a lot of the people I talk
to
um they're not coming to me for should I
quit or not or how do I manage all these
fears they're coming to me and saying
like Okay I'm definitely leaving
can you give me like five pieces of
information to like help me improve how
I'm doing this right and that's a
certain personality type that is like
craves Freedom needs autonomy over the
how they're working like really wants to
like go on an adventure and do their own
thing and those are the people that are
going to like Thrive and make it whereas
there's this meme now of like
I want to quit my job and do my own
thing or become a Creator because people
are seeing you can make money and gain
status in it though the status is
probably questionable at the beginning
um and then they'll say well like oh I I
don't know if I'll be able to like pay
my mortgage and like I'm really
concerned that like this isn't like a
wise thing to do it's like those aren't
actually things that like the people
like
desperately committed to this path that
our thinking or say
just a quick note from one of our
sponsors and we'll get right back to the
episode and very excitingly this episode
is brought to you by Heights Heights is
a brain care smart supplement that I've
actually been taking for the last 12
months ever since I became friends with
Dan marisota who is the founder of
heights and who we had on the podcast in
season one and this season of the
podcast we're also featuring Dr Tara
swart who is a neuroscientist and
psychiatrist so what is Heights well
it's a brain care smart supplement
basically it is a supplement you take
two of them every morning like I do it's
like these two little capsules which
have omega-3 oil in them and they've got
a bunch of multi vitamins as well they
have all of the details on the website
and every single ingredient that they've
got is super high quality and the great
thing is that just by taking two of
these capsules every morning like I do
you get all of the essential micro
nutrients that you need without having
to deal with drinking sludge or anything
fancy like that so the great thing about
Heights is that even if you don't have
one of these absolutely perfect diets at
least you know you have your bases
covered in terms of the micronutrients
that you need it's very easy to sign up
you just go to yourheits.com and then
you sign up to the thing and it's a mail
order they get to you every month or in
three month packets and if you use the
coupon code Ali 15 that's ali15 at
checkout then you'll get 15 off your
first three months of subscription I've
been subscribed to this for the last 12
months I also happen to be an investor
in the company because I believe in the
product and I love how they're fully
evidence-based and absolutely everything
they do and if you're interested in the
evidence base behind all like 20
different ingredients that they've got
here you can check them out on the
website and that'll be linked in the
video description and in the show notes
so thank you so much to Heights for
sponsoring this episode so do you think
you need a level of desperate commitment
where
I mean surely that's not what you're
saying like it's it's it sounds like
what you're saying is you need to have
the sort of Personality that is
desperately committed to the path of
freedom and autonomy and doing your own
thing
and if you have concerns about money and
mortgage and stuff then you're not the
right person to be pursuing this
or is there is there more Nuance there I
think there's just that should like
raise a red flag right okay and be like
if those are your if like Financial
Security is your primary sick like
concern
like probably doing your own thing and
having freedom is also not your primary
concern
right so it's really just checking in
with like what you value now you may
still be somebody that wants to do their
own thing and go on that path
but it's really figuring out like okay
how can I just test this
and that's where like the biggest thing
I've realized is I don't think most
people should quit their jobs what I
think most people should aspire to get
in their life is like a one to three
month break from worker mode
okay so worker mode is kind of like when
you're hyper scheduled you're doing
stuff constantly you're moving towards
stuff you're working for other people or
you're just kind of in like an over
scheduled reality right
and getting that space in your life to
sort of sit back and say like okay what
am I doing with my life what am I
actually afraid of what do I really
value
um how does it feel to be out of worker
mode do I feel really terrible in this
mode okay maybe my job has some hidden
benefits
and like upsides and things I do value
that it wasn't visible to me before
so I think like what is really happening
is like these default scripts are so
powerful in society today
that even the people that are thriving
on that path don't really understand
like why they're thriving on that path
so what I want people to do really is
like reflect more
and say like okay what what do I value
what are the costs I'm paying and what
path makes sense given those things uh
okay that's nice okay so step one figure
out what you value step two figure out I
guess how much that costs in terms of
time money freedom Etc like all the
things that it costs and step three is
at a price worth paying
um yeah so for you I mean we we talked I
think a year ago before you were leaving
medicine
and I mean you it sounded like your
mother cares that you were a doctor
right and that that is a big thing for a
lot of people like the number one
question I asked people is like will the
people closest to you in your family
judge you for making this decision
um
and if so like is that a cost you're
willing to pay
right
and
I imagine like you sort of ran that
calculus and said okay something matters
to me on this YouTube path and
I think like even at the beginning
you're downplaying it a little I think
you're inspiring a lot of people you're
creating jobs for people you're giving
people permission to create and do
things
um that are new and interesting
um
are you I mean you're still dealing with
the challenge of like leaving that path
uh no not really anymore I think when I
yeah when we last spoke I think it was
on your podcast
um I was still like I'm I'm not really
sure about it I'm kind of half in half
out
but when I made the decision that yep it
makes perfect sense to leave at that
point it felt like I had a lot of
clarity and
realized it it was really I think what
was holding me back was
feeling like oh to be honest I could
always go to go back to medicine if I
want to
and in a way it was always an option and
in a way it kind of still is an option
but it took Lewis hose on School of
greatness podcaster prod me to be like
are you saying that if you just if you
were desperate for money you would
actually go back and do medicine
twitch my response was no like I can try
better ways to earn money yeah there are
far easier and more for me more
interesting ways to earn money and for
me what I realized is that
you know if I if I Trot my life back
from the age of like 11 onwards the
thing that I was doing in my spare time
the thing that I was doing for free was
sitting on a computer programming and
making websites and trying to build cool
stuff and that was the thing I was
thinking about in the shower that was
the thing I was doing at University
while supposedly doing a medical degree
the the main path was never the thing
that I that brought me genuine Joy other
than when I was teaching other medical
students
and so if I you know in this
hypothetical worst case scenario where I
lost absolutely everything and I
remember you saying when you were when
when you were online and my brother's
podcast that hey you know if you lost
everything and you're broken homeless
come over stay in my place and I'll I'll
feed him clothe you for a few months and
I'm just like that's in a in a way
hearing you say that we just sort of
pointed out to me the absurdity of the
thing that I was actually worried about
that like I'm am I really worried about
being broken homeless and alone and no
one will love me forever and it's like
until I'd confronted that idea
and realize that that's that worst case
scenario is actually not is a not that
feasible and B I can recover from it
because of friends family Network and
stuff
then it was more okay to be like you
know what even if in the worst case
scenario I lost everything I probably
still wouldn't go back to Medicine
and it was that that click in my mind
that yeah I'm fully out of this now yeah
that really gave me the peace to be like
you know what this is fine this is great
YouTube channel dies in the next five
years great no worries I'll start a tech
startup I'll learn how to code again
I'll program in web3 solidity or
whatever the thing is there I'll
continue to write I'll continue to teach
and I trust my skills in being able to
make money off of the back of those
things almost by default which means
they don't rely it doesn't rely on
medicine to be the thing that I'm I'm
doing to make money
yeah I I wrote about this in my book
it's it almost sounds like you had a
similar path to me I grew up playing on
computers building websites screwing
around doing like earning money on
random things online selling things on
eBay participating in these online like
simulation NBA leagues and then when I
graduated college
the tech economy was booing and I went
and joined strategy Consulting and made
PowerPoint slides
and like in in my day job I was still
like reading tech tech blogs and like
still screwing around with websites and
writing online and I just wasn't paying
attention to it
um so I think it's a good thing that
these paths are becoming more legible
but for me it was like oh
I sort of had this moment a couple years
into my journey
um I was like writing doing things
online it was like oh wait I'm doing
exactly what I was doing as a kid
it just took me 15 years to remember
this is the things that energized me and
I liked yeah
yeah
um do you ever okay so I often hear from
people okay I'm just going to zoom out a
bit and yeah and so so we're talking
step one figure out what you value step
two figure out how much it costs and
step three make it happen and so right
now I guess we're talking about step one
one way of figuring out what your value
is thinking about what are the things
you were doing as a kid what were the
things that genuinely brought you Joy
what are the things you do outside of
the day job that you would do for free
what are the things you're thinking
about in the shower
um one
I have I've spoken to a few people who
say that you know when when it comes to
this idea of essentially follow your
passion and figure out what your passion
is that
I don't know I don't really know what
I'm passionate about I go home and I
watch Netflix and I scroll Instagram and
occasionally I'll post a photo on
Instagram but like I don't really have
any clear passions beyond that like I
don't know how how can I figure out and
and you know I've I've got my my day job
as a Management Consultant for example
or a strategy consultant but beyond that
I I get home from work at like midnight
I have to wake up for work at 7am the
next day
I don't you know I kind of want to play
the guitar but like I've never picked up
a Guitar because your work is just too
busy um do you ever get sort of
questions from from people like that how
would you go about I guess giving advice
or giving suggestions to people in that
position but I can I mean I can share my
story that was me
the reason I did not leave my path
sooner is because I didn't have any
imagination for what other possible
paths or lives I could take I was mostly
surrounded by people like me doing
things exactly like I was
um who are also not cultivating an
imagination of different possible lives
so I think what I would say like
basically what I say with to people now
is like different states are possible
there's this state possible where you
can be so energized and like discovering
ideas
and learning new things and reconnecting
with that childhood Joy like that state
is possible I think it is possible for
most people now knowing that state is
possible
how can you raise the urgency in your
life to like go find it now I don't
perfectly know how to find it but there
are a number of things that can help you
find it like certain things like Health
crises will force you there yep
um I don't advise those right
um losses of people in your life can do
that for you I think like the combo of a
Health crisis and losing my grandfather
really like shook me and made me reflect
on like What mattered but still it only
planted the seeds
um that I didn't fully explore even
until I left my job and I think a couple
things two two of the most powerful
experiences for me one was after seven
months of freelancing I decided I would
not look for any work and I would not do
any work
um that I wasn't like fully drawn to do
and I just sort of woke it up woke up I
wandered around Boston I was like
writing I launched my podcasts at the
time I wasn't trying to make money
because like I didn't know how to make
money in the Creator economy at that
point it wasn't called to create our
economy
um and
like I just like it felt right
like
I was just like something feels right I
don't know what this is but I need to
follow this and I have this sense that I
had to protect like the writing
um the things I was doing
um and like making money was like I'd
figure out ways to do that but like I
had to protect that time and the
autonomy and freedom to do those things
um so that kind of committed me to the
uncertain path
um and then the second thing was really
just traveling
and moving abroad to Asia I had started
freelancing again but moved to Asia and
like couldn't find remote freelancing
gigs like I just like was failing
um so I didn't have anything to do also
was a lower cost of living and I sort of
just
like showed up and did the same thing
and again like I started writing again
and like I started to slowly realize
writing is writing seems really
important and I reflected back and it's
like oh wow I've been writing like every
year of my life in some form
um so in 2018 I just decided like right
I need to pay attention like if writing
disappears in my life something has gone
wrong
so that is the state I need to come back
to you need to protect that at all costs
now how I've made money has varied in so
many different ways over the past five
years but like the writing has never
disappeared
yeah so it sounds like part of the
figuring out of what you value is
finding the space to take a break away
from the I guess rat race of continuing
to
you know continuing to be in work mode
and in a way figuring out like re or
almost realizing what you naturally want
to spend your time doing yeah and maybe
for you that sort of naturally just took
over your life like you're already doing
those things
like I think spending 10 years in the
corporate world sort of numbed my
creativity and Imagination
in a way maybe if you start thinking
about these things earlier and younger
it doesn't affect you as much
but a lot of the past five years have
just been a sort of unlearning of like
certain cynical modes being like I don't
know a little too passive a little too
powerless and like realizing oh I I can
show up and do things I want to do
what do you mean
so in the sense that I mean when you're
in the corporate world even if you're
like in an impressive position you're
still constantly asking for permission
and you're constantly being told no you
can't do things
hey this cool new tool we should try
this you can't just like update a
website at a company
like I can do that now I can just like
update a website and come up with a new
service that I'm offering people and
just do it in an hour
um that's like a sixth month to two year
process at a company sometimes
so like going from that state of
possibility which is like very little
possibility you start just like giving
up
ideas of what's possible to like having
to be on your own and self-employed and
starting to like okay how do I
regenerate that like creativity energy
like possibility for life
um
and I think this is why I love following
people like you I sort of just like I
see people like you and other creators
come up with ideas like oh wow that's
really interesting I never thought of
that I could do something like that in a
different way in my own unique way
just a quick little break before we get
right back to the episode and that's
today you know this episode is very
kindly brought to you by short form
short form is the world's best service
for reading summaries of books but it's
more than just book summaries what short
film does is it basically creates a sort
of study guide for tons and tons of
different non-fiction books from all
sorts of genres from self-help and
personal development to money and
history and philosophy it's just got
loads of really interesting books and
they summarize them firstly with a cool
one-page summary but then they also have
chapter by chapter outlines of each book
and in between the chapter summaries
they also have kind of interactive
exercise sections where you can take the
insights from the book and actually
apply them to your life and the other
cool thing about short form is that if
for example an author says something
that is a little bit dodgy or that has
been debunked or kind of disagreed with
with another author then the short form
team will write a note saying that hey
you know this person said this thing
about this topic but actually that has
been debunked by this other person and
they'll bring in another source and so
it's not just a way of getting summaries
of books it's also a way of expanding
your under understanding of the genre as
a whole for example short form have
recently released a summary of building
a second brain a new book by Thiago
Forte and so whether you've read the
book or whether you haven't you can
revisit or visit some of the ideas in
the book and then based on that you can
decide if you want to actually read the
book which is often how I personally use
book summaries so if any of that stands
up your street and you too would like to
try out the world's best service for
summarizing books then head over to
shortform.com forward slash Deep dive
and firstly that will give you a
completely free five-day trial where you
can try it out and see if you like it
and it will also give you 20 off the
annual premium subscription which is the
thing that I personally subscribe to so
thank you so much short form for
sponsoring this episode yeah yeah I
think
often I find kind of through
conversations with people that
another thing that holds them back is so
for example a you know a close friend of
mine is a highly paid strategy
consultant and she's been toying with
the idea of quitting the job
um but one thing that's been holding her
back is the idea that oh currently in my
high paying job as a strategy consultant
I am making
x amount of money which is like I don't
know High six figures or something like
that or low six figures and therefore in
order for me to quit my job I need to
make sure I can make the same amount of
money doing something else and it's like
oh but I can't make the same amount of
money doing something else because it's
oh my how the hell do you make six
figures a year doing good right you know
doing your own thing therefore I
couldn't possibly quit my job because I
need that money to be able to 10 years
from now send kids to private school or
like you know I wanna I wanna save money
I want to get on the property ladder and
therefore I kind of have to stay in this
job because of them because of the the
golden handcuffs in a way
um yeah how how do you how do you
approach that that's that's the cost
part I've never matched my salary when I
left five years ago
um this is the first year maybe I will
come close
um but I don't know and then it's
uncertain after that so like
this is like what costs are you willing
to pay for me I was willing to pay
enormous costs because I had sort of
discovered this path is not a winning
strategy for life for me I was so
certain
after 10 years on that path that like if
I spent five more years in that path I
would definitely become less of a person
I was proud of
and that was so incredibly costly to me
that like replacing my salary was like
this is Trivial like this is my life
and I think
I mean the thing that c did that for me
was five years before quitting my job
like a Health crisis I was out of work
and I had sort of lost my identity I was
just sitting around and like I
desperately wanted my identity back and
I went through this reflection exercise
of like what would happen if I couldn't
work again it was like oh I'd be okay
like I'd have my family I'd have people
to take me in that's why I make the
offer to you and the offer still stands
I'll take you in if you uh go a few
months without salary
um but
yeah it's I was willing to give it up so
like this is why I share my income too
like my income the first five years like
if I look after tax it was like 45
because I was freelancing then like 30
then 25 and then I think last year was
like 55.
[Music]
consulting job is very low
yeah and I was making I think my final
year it was probably about
170 180 us a year and when I left I had
about 50 Grand in savings
um so I sort of said okay I can live for
a year on 50 Grand of savings
I need a year just to like
figure out what I want to do with my
life like my service level plan was like
I want to be a freelance consultant but
I sort of discovered quickly like oh
this is just recreating my previous life
but like slightly less work
um but in that space the less work I was
able to get enough like breathing room
that was like oh I wonder what would
happen to my life
what are the possibilities if I like
keep following this on certain Journey
so like this is the equation I talk
about in my book like it sort of flips
once you add this sense of wonder
possibility to an uncertain
discomfort uncertain discomfort is
terrifying yeah that's pretty scary but
if you pair it with Wonder like ooh what
might also happen
then you can sort of in immunize
yourself for a certain period of time
and I mean this is when I start reading
like people like David White and Rebecca
solnit and like people that are like
giving me courage to like follow these
uncertain Journeys and this is when you
need poetry and literature and like
all these people that are like trust the
flow of the universe like you need that
stuff because like you have no idea what
you're doing and then when you're doing
it at the beginning you I also like
people would ask me what are you doing
and so like I would feel the need to be
like I know exactly what I'm doing
here's my is I had no idea what I was
doing and I was terrified now you like
every time somebody asked me it would
scare me
um so yeah you sort of have to have this
surface level story but at the same time
just this deep sense of like okay
there's a direction I'm gonna follow it
but I I may also be wrong like that's
the deepest humility in the world like I
may be wrong
and I think that's the best way to
follow any path
yeah no that's nice yeah I think I think
it was when I added in the component of
wonder that I still suddenly started to
feel okay with the decision to leave
medicine and pursue this uncertain puff
because and with with medicine and with
most traditional careers there is a
level of certainty you get you know that
okay if I can if I stick at this for
long enough I will get the promotion I
will apply for specialty training in X
number of years then it will take eight
years to become a consultant and then
and then I'll die
um but with the uncertain path it's like
uh right right now I mean I don't really
know what I'm doing my YouTube channel
is kind of going well or maybe it's not
maybe my podcast is doing well or maybe
my side little software business is
doing well or maybe I have nothing at
all I have no side hustles and I just
know I've got enough savings and enough
of a family and friends safety net to be
able to spend a year experimenting and
then I know that if that experiment
fails and I ended up end up needing to
go back to a job great I'll just get
another job but if the experiment
succeeds I guess kind of the upside of
that is that I have figured out a way to
live my life
um that is more in line with the person
that I want to be
and for me it was in there was a lot of
a lot of fear around this uncertainty
but when I added the component of yeah
you know it would be interesting it'll
be kind of interesting to see I'm sure
I'll be able to figure something out and
even if not worst case scenario I've got
family that I can only I can lean on to
kind of help help prop Me Up that made
it feel much more okay and even now even
with like all of the traditional metrics
of success on the YouTube channel and
the business and everything I still feel
the sense of like five years from now I
have absolutely no idea what I'm gonna
be doing oh yeah but it's like a sort of
embracing that with a sense of uh
excitement curiosity Adventure which I
managed to do about half the time the
other half of the time it still feels
really scary and I think oh my God I
don't know what I'm going to be doing
five years from now
well yeah and I think that's the part A
lot of people don't talk about on these
paths and I think people probably miss
when they look at people they deem
successful right they're mapping their
idea of success onto you now like I see
some of the success you're doing but I
also know for sure you're in the same
point as me of like you have no idea we
have no idea what's going to be
happening in five years
yeah as opposed to being in a more
traditional career path
um
but I think one of the benefits of an
uncertain path is it forces a constant
grappling with the uncertainty like one
of the things I didn't realize in my
previous path
was that no one ever asks you why are
you doing this
oh like no no one deeply asked me why
why are you working as a strategy
consultant why would you pursue this
path it was so obvious right because
like
everyone thinks it's impressive and like
everyone knows you make like good money
um then as soon as I quit people like
what are you doing how could you give up
this job what's your plan don't you want
a family don't you want a house don't
you worry about this and like you start
to realize everyone has these fears and
then you realize oh crap I have them too
and now I have to face them
so like I think what I've learned to do
over the the journey over the last five
years is you sort of are able to take
these massive ambiguous like fear of
death fear of being loved fear of not
belonging and like break it down into
like many daily existential crises
so now like I can kind of like in a
mindful way like I see the like fear of
uncertainty coming up and I'm like
I see you I see you all right money
insecurity fear going broke been here
before all right we can deal with you
gotten through this before going through
stretches of not making money for a
couple months we'll be fine
um but it's still there I don't know if
it ever goes away
I was tweeting the other day about like
you know what it feels like to hit 3
million subscribers and kind of How It's
a sort of metrics or a double-edged
sword and you linked me to this article
uh by Paul Jarvis about finding your
enough point
and that like that was that was a good
that was a good article I I was like
there's uh
it's always nice when you post what
you're thinking on Twitter and someone
responds with the absolute perfect
advice that you need to hear
um
this this idea of
figuring out what is enough is something
that I continue to Grapple with
in the sense that
you know I'm in a very privileged
position now where it's like oh the
business is growing and growing and
growing and it's like now I need to
decide how much do I want to continue to
stress out in terms of you know numbers
going up but another part of me is also
like I need I need to make sure the
numbers continue going up because I need
to have a safety net safety net of 10
million in stocks and shares and crypto
and real estate and crypto is a bit
volatile anyway so I need to make sure
that I have at least enough money to be
able to four percent return make at
least 100K a year off of just the
investment returns and it's like the
point of enough I haven't really figured
it out figured out what it is but it
keep it's a very high number right now
and it keeps on getting bigger and
bigger as the business grows and I know
that that kind of thinking left
unchecked or like not examined it's just
like generally very unhelpful and not a
way to live a live a happy life um I
wonder if you can share your perspective
on how do you figure out what is enough
for you and at what point you can stop
pursuing more in the sense of money and
fame and numbers and and ambition and
promotions and all of those traditional
metrics of success
yeah so I think this goes with another
default script the default like
Drive in our world is more
it's always going to be more so unless
you're explicitly defining
an alternative to more it is more right
and I think that is good to sort of
acknowledge because I mean you have
employees now
so like unless you're telling them we're
not trying to make as much money as
possible that is the Assumption in like
a business and a job things right
um so you could probably do interesting
things I mean like Paul Jarvis to find
okay I'm not hiring employees ever that
is a constraint he created that doesn't
limit the amount of income he can earn
but it does limit it to a certain degree
um yeah and then I think what you can do
is like just I attempted to write my own
definition I can read mine I wrote it in
the book yeah what is yours
foreign
defined it in the book so I basically
just decided like Jarvis is like I
should just Define what enough is and
like write out my definition
so
let's see bringing up my Kindle
highlights from the book as well
yeah you get the
branding so
um enough is knowing that no amount of
money in my bank account will ever
satisfy my deepest fears it's knowing
that I have enough friends that would
gladly open their door and share a meal
if I was ever in need it's the feeling
that I've been able to spend my time
over an extended stretch of time working
on projects that are meaningful to me
helping people with a spirit of
generosity and having enough space and
time in my life to stay energized to
keep doing this over the long term
enough is seeing a clear opportunity
that will increase my earnings in the
short term but knowing that saying no
might open me up to things that could be
even more valuable in ways that are hard
to understand enough is knowing that the
clothes fancy meal or latest gadget will
not make me happier but also that buying
such things won't mean that I'm going to
end up broke enough is having meaningful
conversations with people that inspire
me people that I love or people that
support me nice
how how often do you return to that
definition like how is it does it help
you in kind of day-to-day life
yeah I I think by writing these things I
think by doing a lot of my writing it's
a sort of ongoing reminder to myself
that I'm trying to live a sort of
principled life
and
I think by writing about these things
I'm a lot of what I'm trying to do is
just hold myself accountable like I'm
saying these things matter like putting
generosity over making my own money okay
how do I actually do that
um am I bullshitting on that like how am
I actually doing that and then also not
being too stuck to these stories I tell
about myself
and like trying to do things just to
like virtue signal like I want to do
things that are really aligned with like
how I'm wired I love helping people I
love like connecting with people I love
helping random people on the internet
and like navigate their paths I love
these things and like that's why I've
kept doing them
um but I don't want to be like
unnecessarily tied to like oh I have to
do these things because I'm writing
about it um so it's just constant
reflection and trying to be honest with
what I really care about
just a quick note from one of our
sponsors and we'll get right back to the
episode and this episode is very kindly
brought to you by skillshare if you
haven't heard by now skillshare is one
of the world's leading platforms for
online classes for online education
they've got thousands and thousands of
classes on all sorts of topics from
business entrepreneurship lifestyle
design cooking interior design loads of
stuff and very excitingly I have
actually been teaching on skillshare
since 2019 and I've got 13 classes on
skillshare yes 13 classes and you can
access all of them completely free of
charge by going to skillshare.com
forward slash Deep dive and that link
will give you a free one month trial to
skillshare during which you can watch
any and all of my classes one class you
might be interested in is my YouTube for
beginners class if you've ever thought
about starting a YouTube channel this is
the class for you I'll take you step by
step across like three four hours
something like that through all of the
steps you need to take to make your
first two videos on YouTube how to do
the channel art how to think of a name
all of that fun stuff and loads of
people have taken that class and said
that that class was so good that they
would have literally paid hundreds of
dollars for it but you get it completely
for free on skillshare by going to
skillshare.com forward slash deep dive
after your trial's over you can choose
to continue the subscription if you like
and you can access the thousands of
classes skillshare house from other
teachers including people that I know
people I'm friends with like Thomas
Frank and Nathaniel Drew but yeah the
main reason to check out skillshare of
course is that you want to check out my
classes if you want to learn about
productivity and video editing and
youtubing and even cooking so head over
to skillshare.com forward slash Deep
dive and thank you so much skillshare
for sponsoring this episode uh one thing
I wanted to ask you about is kind of
this idea of following energy versus
following money and I wonder if you can
elaborate on on what you mean by that
there's a lot of people that are very
hyper analytical we grew up in a world
that clearly values money and it's very
easy to understand
like things that turn into money
I think the mistake is over indexing on
that and just not paying attention to
like what the actual energy of like what
you're doing is
and
like I think people can get trapped in
like local minimum
where they're optimizing around like
something that produces money
um and possibly even miss out on sort of
those unknown opportunities that can
emerge
from just giving yourself time to
explore other things or saying no to
those things
right
yeah I imagine early on in doing YouTube
videos
you sort of noticed oh I like this
like in some ways like you can't
actually make it
to where you are now without actually
being energized by what you were doing
yeah absolutely especially at the early
stage yeah
so
I think this advice is like super
important at the early stage where like
people think the issue especially like
if they want to follow a Creator path
it's like I need to make money as soon
as possible
I think a lot of times that will
short-circuit this exploratory mode and
like sort of finding paths where you can
ride that energy wave
um
such that like people can't actually
make it to that second phase where they
can commit to that path
so there's a lot of different ways you
can do this right you can do like all
right I'm gonna do a 30 day challenge
where where like I call it ship quit and
learn
um
ship 30 posts 30 videos 30 something
even do like seven do it small enough
that you know you can do it
design it to quit
but like in the process of doing it
notice oh do I like this do I want to do
more do I find myself trying to learn
more things if you're like resenting
doing the post on like the fourth day
like you need to pay attention to that
you'll never make it to a hundred
I love that that's sick writing the
energy wave yeah this is like basically
the concept of my whole book uh it's
about like how the secret to effortless
and sustainable productivity is to
figure out what energizes you and
go towards that and if you're having to
do stuff like your day job that doesn't
energize you then there is a way that
you can approach it to an extent that
makes it more of an energy source and
less of an energy drain
and I think that's why for me like
making YouTube videos doing these
podcasts the the stuff I've done has
almost never felt like uh chore there
are still you know there are times when
it does where it's like oh let me
sponsor deadline we should probably get
that video tomorrow
um but those are very very few and
broadly I feel enormously energized by
doing
videos and stuff and that's great and
it's just such a competitive Advantage
as well in the sense that if someone
else is trying to be a YouTuber because
they want to make money but I'm doing it
because I genuinely enjoy it and it
energizes me it's like you'll win I am
way more likely to keep going than the
other person that is not going to see
any kind of momentum on the money front
for a while yeah like I mean I see a lot
of people start newsletters and stuff
and I sort of know I'll probably make it
to like a thousand issues of my
newsletter
like I've I've tapped into something and
so I can play a a slower and stupider
game in some ways like I don't need to
worry about monetizing or scaling or
growing it or being super successful
because that's sort of taking care of
itself and like as long as I protect the
energy that like is naturally going
there anyway I'm gonna keep doing it
so then in some ways ambition
and how much money or like how
successful you want to be is really a
question of like speed and time
so it's like and I think I've started to
like rethink ambition over the past
couple of years as I've like gotten more
of a footing on my path it's like okay I
can be ambition ambitious just over like
a longer stretch of time
like I don't need to crush it in three
months but like I can sort of have a a
sensible plan to like take the three to
five year plan and like because doing it
at that speed will be a little more fun
for me yeah
you know I was listening to a good um uh
Cal Newport chatting to Tim Ferriss on
Tim ferriss's podcast
yeah yeah slow productivity or low
productivity yeah where it's like you're
you're optimizing for creating
meaningful output across a 10-year time
Horizon rather than a 10-day time
horizon or a 10 week time Horizon and
that just means that you know if I was
thinking about can I make cool stuff in
the world in a way that I enjoy and that
help is helpful to other people that
energizes me but I'm doing it over the
next five to ten years then it means
that I probably spend more time deep
working on my book for example rather
than feeling the need to every single
week bang out another two YouTube videos
because that's all very sort of
short-term productivity whereas the more
longer term tends to be the thing that's
uh but potentially the thing that is
tends to be a little bit more needle
moving but also I guess it just depends
on what what you enjoy there are some
people that love the high octaneness of
putting out content every week or even
every day or even multiple times a day
and there are others of us that would
rather kind of take it a bit slow and as
long as
we're doing the things that we enjoy
we're being we're feeling energized by
them and I guess they're useful to other
people in some way then that's a that's
a reasonable path as well I think in the
last year I've sort of realized
I'm on a path that's really aligned with
what I value
so
I I don't pay much of a cost for like
worrying that other people see my path
as low status I'm like huh whatever
um I also am not too worried about like
not making tons of money I just like
don't have much material aspirations nor
does my wife
um
so
and I highly value the like creative
connection and that creative mode like
it's so valuable to me it gives my life
so much energy and
um
like just keeps me going like at such a
deep level so
I can sort of look around and like see
people panicking about money like
starting in this path is like I'll
probably still be doing this in like 20
years yeah and the way the internet's
going like you can sort of just bet on
like okay you'll probably be okay
because like this is just an expanding
space and like you'll figure out some
stuff you'll slowly get better maybe
that's slower rate than other people but
you'll be fine
yeah
yeah no like that okay so so coming back
to our sort of anchoring three three
part framework of like step one figure
out what you value step two figure out
how much it costs and step three
figure out if you're willing to make
that trade so we then figure out what
you value we talked about like the
shower test or the free time test what
do you find yourself drawn to in your in
your free time
um I love this idea of yours of like um
ship learn quit organic ship learn quit
try something else ah chip quit learn
that's one so try try something out you
know thinking like oh maybe I want to be
some kind of YouTuber okay cool try
making videos for four weeks once a week
and and see and see how you feel uh
learn from that and the more of these
experiments you run on yourself the more
of a barometer you get for what are the
things that I value and one way of doing
that is to figure out did this thing
give me energy did I feel almost
effortlessly incentivized to continue
or did it feel like a chore
and I guess if I'm if I think of people
I know who say that they don't really
have any hobbies and they don't really
know what they value they tend to have
done very few experiments of this kind
they'll have ideas in their head of like
oh maybe it would be cool to do XYZ but
then they won't they won't try it out
because and you know this is
I guess the kind of the way we're taught
is that like
the festival perfect yeah it has to be
perfect and it has to be long term it
has to be sustainable it's like oh maybe
I want to be a YouTuber but I can't
imagine what that looks like for the
next 10 years it's like don't worry
about the next 10 years I should get I
should take this advice myself don't
worry about the next 10 years just try
it for now try it for a little bit and
see if energizes you and if it does then
that gives you a decent data point then
that is something that you potentially
value so other than what do you what do
you find yourself doing in your spare
time and run experiments and see what
Vibes with you do you have any other
strategies for helping helping people
figure out what they actually value in
life I guess that's a big question yeah
I mean what what you value I think
reflecting asking the hard questions we
all know the hard questions we need to
ask
um it's just really sitting down and
like grappling with our answers
sometimes we don't like our own answers
we hide from them
I think in terms of like finding things
you actually want to do
what I've found is that if you give
people enough free time and this is why
I think like finding a way to take a one
month sabbatical in your life is so
vital to like reclaiming the energy in
your life
like people will just start doing stuff
in like 99 of cases of people I talk to
there they start to oh wow I literally
forgot I liked playing this instrument
as a kid and I just started doing it
and like you hear these stories over and
over again
um oh I started volunteering at a local
Garden I was just like walking around my
neighborhood and I like remembered I
like engaging in my local community
so it's like we all have this like I
don't think this is a hard thing to do I
think the thing that's hard is we often
have things that out compete or zap our
energy
um and the thing that's worth noting is
like this is why it's so important just
to like get reps of experiments like
this is why I love helping people to
like just start stuff
do a hundred tweets do five posts do
five YouTube videos like even just do
one
um just to realize you can do stuff in
the world we don't need permission
anymore we have more freedom to do more
things than like at any time before it's
such an amazing time to be alive
um and then these things compound like I
see even you like I feel like you're
launching and trying new things like all
the time
and that's that makes so much sense
because you realize like the more
experiments you do like you constantly
want to like keep learning and like keep
finding those new spaces those new ideas
those new avenues those new energy slip
streams
yeah yeah and I guess as we as we run
the experiments like if it whether it's
in my personal life or as a team in the
business where we're getting really
useful data points from them like we you
know we run an experiment thinking oh we
should totally start a whole new YouTube
channel the part-time Creator Academy
teaching people how to be creators then
we tried it you know planned it out did
the whole thing
um bashed out you know we had like set
like seven videos filmed and ready to go
and it would you know just the feeling
of the project was so energy draining
like oh this is such a heavy lift we
don't have the capacity to do this if we
wanted to do this thing it would require
us to hire an extra probably five people
or cut some other projects and
in the end we decided you know what
let's take the loss on this uh it was an
experiment we tried it out it didn't
work the idea is still good someone
someone could totally take that idea and
run with it but it's not something we
want to do right now and then we pivoted
from that into thinking what if we just
did it as a newsletter and a Twitter
account instead it's like oh all of a
sudden it's like that feels like that
feels like all of the weight has been
lifted off because now that's a thing
that you know other people in the team
can write and can take ownership of
rather than me having to be on camera at
all times so that was great so now we've
built this thing and we're like okay
cool let's connect it to the course and
now that's sparked the opportunity to
potentially collab with other creators
and create courses for them because
that's fun and we're all about sharing
ideas and it's like doing an experiment
and just sort of doing it quickly and
realizing okay what is the data what is
the learning we've gotten from this
experiment and even if lots of time and
money has gone into it you know that's
some cost fallacy it's way better to
quit a thing early or could a thing when
you know it's not right than it is to
worry oh but we spent like six months
preparing for this already
and so I think that attitude of
experimentation applied to life in
general you know like I've been saying
for the last couple of years I really
want to travel the world and do the
digital Nomad thing the appropriate
response there and the advice I would
give to someone else is well just try it
out for two weeks see what happens and
so right now I'm in Wales we're on this
four day team Retreat we're still making
the podcast happen the internet's a bit
sketch it's cut out a couple of times
but oh well it's working the setup looks
good No One's Gonna explain about
quality issues because the camera's sick
um this is great I'm currently looking
on over over these like ridiculous
fields that like some cows and sheep and
stuff and this is so nice and so what I
should do is probably experiment with
okay my hypothesis is that I think I
would enjoy the digital Nomad lifestyle
great let's experiment let's try it out
for two weeks let's see what happens
cool I enjoyed that all right that's
that's good data points let's now try it
out for a month let's now try it out for
three whereas I think the thing that's
holding me back on that front is
thinking that oh in order for me to
experience the digital Nomad lifestyle I
need to wait for the conditions to be
perfect I need to have a whole year
right where I have nothing to do and no
responsibilities and then I can take
away get a one-way ticket to Bali or
something like that and that's just such
a dumb way of looking at it and I it's
only now saying this out loud that I
realized that that's subconsciously how
I've been approaching it because I
haven't been consciously thinking about
what is the smallest unit of
experimentation that I could apply to
get to gather data about this hypothesis
that maybe I would enjoy this kind of
Lifestyle
yeah and I think this is a key point
which is like you're starting with like
a story of like a script of like what a
digital Nomad should be
when like what you're really trying to
test is like would it be cool to work in
a different location than my home base
yeah that's it yeah right
um and I think where people get into a
lot of trouble on traditional paths or
other things is like when they're trying
to be something
rather than like literally just be
themselves
be something rather than be themselves
okay like trying to imagine to be a
creator
yeah like ramdas talks about this idea
of like the this space suit like you go
on Earth and you wear this space suit of
like this person that's you
and you're sort of Performing all these
roles and like
really The Human Experience is
remembering that like you aren't that
spacesuit
you're just like
this human body
and like you're just living in the
present moment
um
so what how how does that apply to like
work right we're like people don't want
to leave their jobs because like I am a
consultant that makes this amount of
money and like I need to be that kind of
person that makes this amount of money
right when it's like the real question
to ask is like are you feeling this fire
in your soul that is telling you there
is possibility and wonder to be found in
the world and like how long are you
going to not listen to that voice
in service of like continuing to
maintain this beingness of that role and
identity yeah
yeah no absolutely
like even the the digital Nomad stuff I
sort of stumbled upon it by accident I
took a one month trip to Asia
and I landed a freelance project right
before I left because
somebody reached out and I said like not
available they're like we like your
background though can you please help us
so I was like all right I'll do it 10
hours a week from Asia for like double
what I normally charge and they're like
fine I'm like oh wow so I like fully
funded my trip and then I found myself
in Bali this is the first year of
self-employment
um I was staying at a 20 a night Surfer
hostel oh overlooking like Surfers with
my friend and like I walked down the
Rock Ledge to a cafe and I'm like
overlooking the ocean doing work paying
like way more than twenty dollars an
hour
and I'm just like oh wow I never even
thought about the possibility of doing
this yeah
and I sort of had this like what else
like haven't I imagined and that sort of
just expanded my imagination and on that
trip I decided I'm gonna move back to
Asia
and like figure it out but yeah and I
really didn't have a plan and like I
really was almost like crippled by the
questions that summer from my family
like that people were asking what's your
plan like you don't have any money like
you're gonna run out of money what are
you gonna do for Health Care are you
gonna move there forever and like
there's just a experiment I was gonna do
it for three months like I didn't have a
plan I didn't know if I would like not
have work
um but a month into my trip like it
started to change my life and met my now
wife
um
and
that sort of changed everything
um yeah yeah this is definitely
something I need to be I I I I want to
be and and will be more mindful obvious
this attitude of experimentation like I
was I was good at it though
yeah no I think I'm good at it I think
I'm good at it at work I think I'm less
good at it in my personal life
um I was re-listing to an an interview I
did with Noah Kagan on like back back in
the day when I was doing live streams on
the YouTube channel um because we
released that as an episode on the Deep
dive as like an in-betweener sword and
one thing he said he was like hey you
know I've always been interested in the
idea of living in a van so I just rented
a van and I'm gonna live in it for three
weeks
and I was just I I was listening to that
like now two years later after the
interview thinking damn that's such a
good attitude it's like I've also kind
of been watching the van life videos on
YouTube and thinking huh I wonder what
it would be like to live in a van and
I'm just not taking that step to be like
I could just rent a van for a week and
see what happens
and I've just been caught up in the
default script of oh I guess I'm living
in London now I'm I guess I have a
studio in an office therefore I guess
every day I have to go to work and like
on the weekends I guess I go home and
see my family
but I could do all that from move out
and just to see what it's like living an
event like why why not and I was kind of
like thinking thinking to myself like
that that exact thought process that you
had is like damn what other things have
I just thought of that oh it would be
cool to do X and just not done the extra
step of all right how do I try this out
for a few days or for a week or for a
couple of weeks or just like how do I
turn this into an experiment and let's
see what happens
I do wonder if in certain cities like I
was living in Boston in New York
for a long time and in London if there's
just this sort of like gravitational
pull that
like Narrows out that imagination like I
think moving to Asia for me sort of gave
me this distance from my default culture
that new ideas started seeping in in
interesting ways
so I and maybe Wales can do that for you
yeah maybe because like thinking looking
at the hills and thinking you know what
yeah you're looking out at like a
vastness right yeah I'll turn the camera
around so the people in the post office
can see it if you're listening to this
on the thing it's like it's just insane
I'm currently sitting on a snooker table
and there's this like enormous I mean I
don't think it's going to focus because
the lighting's all off but it's just
this enormous like vast expansive Hills
and trees and stuff
and it's just really cool it's a good
good place to yeah to be here for a
little reset and the other thing is that
even then it doesn't I think it's it's
easy to get too precious about this
stuff that oh yeah I need to go out into
nature so that I can think about my life
but like for me if I had just spent a
set of five minute timer and just be
like for the next five minutes I'm just
gonna brainstorm cool [ __ ] that I can do
for a week at a time I I would have come
up with living in about an hour I'll
just be cool and it's just I've never
had the thought that I'll let me just
spend five minutes thinking about this
and then of course yeah I can do all
this cool stuff and five minutes is not
that much time but I guess it's so easy
to get into again this default thing of
life going on where you just don't
genuinely don't stop to think huh let me
just ask myself a question you know what
am I procrastinating from what's
something cool I could do what's
something that I would be glad I did 10
years from now like these sorts of
prompts I think are really helpful in
just ex forcing yourself to just get
outside of the mode of like the mode of
life where you're following the script
that you've always followed and just
actually thinking a little bit it
outside the box to use that to use that
phrase
I think it's very hard I think
even on my path I sort of gotten a
routine of like living this sort of
simpler existence and doing the same
things over and over again
and like I'm constantly amazed that like
I'm
like oh I should have thought of this
idea earlier like recently I've decided
to lean back into my podcast
and I sort of came up with the idea of
like oh what if I like sought out a
sponsor and like I just put that in my
newsletter and then somebody reached out
and said we'll sponsor you
and I was like oh I could have like came
up with this two years ago oh yeah I was
thinking of sponsoring you as well I was
I saw your page I was like oh we should
totally sponsor that podcast
yeah and it's uh yeah it's just constant
Challenge and I I think this is
something if you are going to be on an
uncertain path like
this is a challenge and something you
need to have a plan for like how do I
continue to experiment how do I continue
to come up with new ideas and like if
you don't like doing those things like
you probably shouldn't follow an
unconventional path one of the benefits
of like having a job in a more stable
career is like a lot of that thinking is
sort of just baked into the path for you
yeah now I would still advise you to
like figure out like if you really value
some of the benefits you're getting
um but you there's just less to worry
about and sort of like constantly
refreshing your life and injecting new
things and into your path
have you gotten any mileage out of those
sorts of long-termy thinking type
exercises of like imagine yourself in
your deathbed and like what would people
say at your funeral that kind of stuff
do you ever think about that
I think so a book that has really stuck
with me is two sides with Mori it talks
about this guy at the end of his life
um I quoted towards the end of my book
too
um he's sort of he's in his late 70s
he's dying of Lou Gehrig's Disease and
it's doubly interesting because the
writer Mitch album is at the peak of his
work career and he sort of realizes that
oh this is my professor he's dying I
lost touch with him for 15 years because
I got carried away in my career how am I
going to reorient My Life
um so it's a really powerful book
because
it talks about this guy Mori who's Fully
Alive and engaged with life at the end
of his life so I think a lot about role
models in terms of like how they're
showing up in their life
so I really admire like older creative
men
like people like Mori his story
um I look up to people like Seth Godin I
think he's like in his 60s now he
probably doesn't want us like saying
that but
um he's still connected energized like
seems Fully Alive with like what he's
doing
um I really admire people like Jim
O'Shaughnessy who's like still injecting
this playful curiosity
um at his age and like that's kind of
like my aim in terms of a state I want
to arrive at later in life
so yeah
I don't think the way to get there is to
like play the like okay I need to play
the retirement game of like maxing out
of like aiming at a Target retirement
number
like can that help sure like I don't
want to be broke when I'm older
but it's like I need to sort of like
have an intuition that I'm like headed
towards that state
um and this is what made it so easy to
walk away from my previous path I just I
wasn't on a path to get there I was on a
path to show up like a lot of the men I
was surrounded by who are like cynical
overweight slightly disillusioned good
bank accounts but like I don't know some
of them had been like divorced
disconnected from their kids like I
don't want any of that okay so we spent
a bunch of time figuring out this whole
values question like what are the step
one of the kind of
breaking away from the default path step
two we talked about uh what is the
figuring figuring the cost of this and
we touched a little a little on the
money on the money side of things but I
wonder if you can elaborate on this like
how do we genuinely figure out what it
costs to to have a to to take one of
these non-traditional more
um uncertain paths yeah so the financial
costs are obvious right you're trading
like certain income for uncertain income
and most people worry enough about money
that they are hyper focused on this cost
the other costs you need to be aware of
are what other people think of you
I and this is a really important one
especially the people close in your life
do not be surprised if you take an
unconventional path that you will
receive less support than you expect
because you will be feeling more
uncertain
about your path which means you will
crave
like affirmation and appreciation from
others more and you will notice that the
lack of active encouragement from others
feels like you're not being supported
and that can be really hard
for people early on a path
and figuring out like how you're going
to deal with that and this is why I
think one of the most important things
and a real reason to share
ideas in public and write about your
journey is to like find the others
like finding other people you can
literally just be around and you don't
have to have the conversation of like
why are you doing this don't you worry
about X it's like no we can just sort of
like both exist in our uncertainty for
like not knowing what we're doing and
like
connect on that vulnerability
it's a big reason why I'm in Austin like
there's just a lot of people doing these
weird internet online Creator paths and
like people in your audience or my
audience might look at us and say wow
impressive people
but like
we're kind of low status in the Normie
world still
like if if I try to talk about what I do
and like fancier circles people like
what are you what are you talking about
why would you do any of this yeah
um so you sort of need
those connections of like people who do
understand you and and want to actively
encourage you this is why like I've
really tried to lean into like actively
encouraging and supporting people across
all different levels doing these past
because like I want to keep people in
the game because like I need friends
yeah
can we yeah like can we zoom in zoom
into the money point a little bit
because I think yeah there's there's
something there around the fear of uh oh
the perceived cost in terms of money
being different to the actual cost in
terms of money
yeah I my relationship with money
changed dramatically
from being employed to being
self-employed
I went from making
High income that was increasing
throughout my career pretty steadily to
making no income for the first three
months after quitting my job
and
I sort of like had this bold hunch like
I could figure it out but like I totally
underestimated how terrible it would
feel to not make money especially I was
living in New York spending like five
thousand dollars a month
it felt so painful
to like start to see my savings go down
I felt terrible I felt like an idiot and
I sort of realized like oh this was
there the entire time
it was just like I never had to stare it
in the face
when I quit my job so like I drastically
took action in both directions one was
to like lower my cost of living and I
quickly like started dropping things out
of my life and almost bearing like no
cost like I just stopped going out to
restaurants I started cooking at home I
started eating much cheaper and I'm like
what was I doing for the last several
years like I'm not less Happy by giving
up any of that but that was like a
decent amount of money I was spending
and like
even I thought like I like kind of
needed those things right that was like
part of what made me happy and like
totally not true I didn't value it
um and then lowered my call and then the
the other side of that is like I think
one thing people underestimate when they
go without income is like how motivated
they will be
I was ready to like do any kind of work
for any kind of money at the beginning
of my journey like
I like I held signs in New York like
walking around like trying to find
people for a survey like I got hired for
a gig to like do research for this um
private Equity Firm and I was just like
walking around like holding up this sign
trying to find people with wearing a
certain type of shoe and it was like I
don't care I'll do I'll do anything to
make money at this point make the pain
go away but like leaning into that to
like
realize oh you can ride this wave of
energy at the beginning
I think that eventually like Mellows out
a little so like what I say at the
beginning is like lean into your money
insecurity and like just go hard and try
to earn money in a number of different
ways in your first six months but like
eventually you do need to shift into a
mode where like you're making money in a
way that's connected with yourself and
that's where this like deeper stuff
comes in
but then I sort of got stuck in this
like minimized spend mode especially
after moving to Asia I was like tracking
expenses like minimizing spend
and I was short-circuiting my creativity
I created a course at one point and I
remember going into a store looking at
these webcams
and like I it's like there's like 100
camera and there was like a 40 camera
and I just like toiled I ended up buying
the 40 camera
and like looking back this is so silly I
should have just bought like the 100
camera it would have like raised my
ambitions a little
and like I was just like short
circuiting my energy by like worrying
too much about money
um so I was playing accountant and I
read this book like I was playing
accountant
rather than like living my life so I
sort of just decided like I don't want
to be spending my day tracking my
spending and counting my dollars like I
was using a spending app got my spending
to under a thousand dollars a month like
I was still pretty happy but like I was
playing accountant I wasn't actually
like living my life and that was when I
started like leaning back into like the
creating stuff like sharing on Twitter a
little more like writing a little more
publicly and like being a little Bolder
um and digging out of that like even the
other day like I was thinking about
relaunching my podcast and doing an
in-person one and I was like you know
what like I'm wasting zero time on
buying the best equipment I bought like
a 260 cam link I bought a share mic and
I was like you know I'm not playing
accountant I'm just like gonna commit go
all in and like I think this is a better
bet
um so I'm I'm still learning to like
play with money
um
and investing in myself has been really
hard for me to do because I went into it
with like I need to break even I can't
like spend more than I make I don't want
to see my savings go down
whereas like now I'm five years in and
I'm like I'm giving myself these pep
talks I'm like Paul you've sort of found
your footing you wrote a book about like
being confident on your path
like okay you can be a little Bolder
you're not gonna turn into this hustle
bro like I don't think there's any
chance I'm gonna turn into a like hustle
Pro productivity bro
um I'm not gonna start like money maxing
like I'm gonna be okay
I can like be a 30 Bolder and like still
be myself yeah um
yeah
um can we talk about the book a little
bit so how how did you how did you just
write a book yeah we gotta talk about
your journey too oh yeah we could do
that but like yeah let's do yours first
yeah how did how did you just write a
book
so mine was very emergent uh like I said
at the beginning
um I was writing about this stuff from
as soon as I left my job I sort of dealt
with this jolt of reality of like this
increased freedom in space in my life
and like what does this all mean like
why why was it so hard to leave my path
why was it so weird feeling when I
became self-employed so writing about
that and then just consistently
committing to that after moving to Asia
and then in 2020 the whole world sort of
like showed up
like asking these deep questions about
work and my readership just like
exploded and I started just having more
and more conversations with people I had
these weekly curiosity conversations and
I actually just like recently paused
them but I had 383 of these over the
last five years about people's
relationship with work
and what would happen over and over
again is people would tell me things and
I'd be like Have you shared this with
anyone it's like well I've said like a
little to my spouse but like I can't
talk about this with anyone
so I was like oh wow what I'm writing
about is like this hidden knowledge that
nobody feels like they can talk about
publicly
like I'm just gonna like lean into this
right more
and then at the end of the year like I
had like three or four people that said
to me Paul you have this like
broad range of ideas like where do I
start like can you just write a book
um and
I had an interesting trade-off at the
time Thiago Forte was running a boot
camp with Billy Bros around like okay
how to take your course to the next
level and I had this Consulting skills
course that was like really crushing it
in 2020
um because of remote work
and I had a clear path like it was like
okay if I double down on that and go all
in on this this year
I could probably make a lot more money
and I asked myself like what would I do
if I made more money it was like oh I
would use that to get more free time to
write it was like oh why don't I just
write I'm in Taiwan for the year my cost
of living is lower
um I'm really drawn to like write about
this stuff and I just committed to write
the book
early on I thought it would be just like
I'll package some essays uh from my
newsletter and just ship it
um and then in the first three months I
really realized wow this is this is a
deeper like
um just self-reflection exercise of like
figuring out what this is all meant to
me
and I knew there was something deeper to
say and I just sort of committed to
the book and it I sort of had this sense
of like I know I can end up somewhere
and I'll know when I'm heading towards
that now and I know I can get there
um so I spent 13 months writing it and
that was kind of the main priority for
the entire year and
yeah it was a magical experience
actually
um
the introduction when I read about like
why this stuff matters to me didn't come
to me until like my final weeks in
Taiwan
and I was feeling so frustrated I went
out for a motorcycle ride
and
like the ideas just came to me and I
just broke down in tears and I realized
it had like everything to do with my
parents and like they didn't go to
college they had to do the default path
and they felt like they sacrificed so
much so that like I could succeed
and I realized like what they gave me
was like the freedom to dream
and
I for the first time this was like
October so seven eight months ago
like finally felt like
I can say this as a human like it
matters to like dream
to like do Brave things to like
create
and
yeah and I I think these things are
important and before that
I didn't have the courage to say that
stuff I always couched my stuff or like
qualified it
I was like you know what like I I really
think this matters and I think I can
help people with this stuff
and I'm just gonna say it
and so it was a really powerful
experience for me and
I imagine you're going through something
similar like it's been really cool to
watch your journey too because I feel
like
it's allowed you to understand your own
Journey better too
hmm
yeah yeah the Journey of writing a book
is Jen is is interesting
um a lot of like
windy turns along the way
but I'm very happy with the direction
that it's currently going and the plan
is today tomorrow and the day after bang
out a first draft of one of the chapters
each day
um nice so we'll we'll see what happens
there
um yeah I was just kind of thinking as
you were saying that that like your path
is almost
like it's it's weird when it comes to
the Creator economy and kind of making a
living doing what you love on the side
and all that all that stuff
that a lot of people's paths seem to
follow the same general trajectory of
I started making stuff
that I liked in your case I started
writing about this job stuff and this
career stuff and I did that a bunch of
times and I realized I liked doing it
and that it energized me so I kept on
continuing to do it and then along the
way people started to find out about it
and then what you did was you had your
calendar link where for free anyone
could just book a call with you and you
would just talk to them completely for
free on the internet for like 383 times
so through that you're speaking to
people about this thing that you really
care about this thing that energizes you
and then the next step is you're like
all right cool this is interesting let's
write a book about it and then you would
go and write a book about it and
self-publish the book and it's like
now your newsletter you know if you
wanted to get more and more lucrative
sponsors on it you could probably easily
do that like there's all these options
that you now have for making money out
of this thing because you've now done it
to the point where
you were just following your curiosity
you've been you know built an audience
now and and it's just like
you know when people ask oh how do I
quit my job to become a Creator that's
literally the method it's like step one
yeah experiment with lots of things
figure out the one that energizes you do
that repeatedly at some point you can
quit your job if you've got enough of a
financial safety net et cetera Etc
and then just keep on doing that
repeatedly more people will find you and
then you will just figure out
opportunities along the way whether it's
a book whether it's a course whether
it's sponsorships whether it's
Consulting gigs whether it's corporate
speaking for 100 grand for an hour of
speaking like there will there will be
stuff that comes up by virtue of the
fact that you are showing up there in
the world and providing value I guess in
inverted commas but in a way that
energizes you in a way that feels
somewhat effortless for you like even if
you weren't making money you would
probably continue doing the writing
thing and so it's about finding finding
finding that thing like what is that
thing for for people listening if
they're interested in for example
quitting their job or like doing the
Creator thing or doing the business
thing
and like I think it's it's the same with
startup Founders like the startup
Founders that exit what do they do they
they tend to take a few months off and
then they just start another company
because they just love it in theory uh
or maybe they're just chasing more and
more but like you know mostly the people
I've spoken to genuinely just enjoy
building companies and like oh great now
I can start a new app
and I think what we're all trying to do
is just get to that state where we can
be showing up and doing the things that
genuinely intrinsically motivate us
which as a side effect happen to make
enough money to sustain our our
lifestyle
I think that's spot on I think the
opportunity and upshot of doing your own
thing is that you can lower the
percentage of things you're doing that
you sort of resent or like you feel like
you're sacrificing
right in a job you may just have like
too many things
and this was my case like it was just
doing too many things that I thought
were Silly pointless or just like
grueling to power through like I still
do some of those things it's just less
so it means there's more space for that
creativity and curiosity to stay alive
and that is really important to me
and if it's important to you it's it's
possible and I think this is kind of
what I was trying to get at and don't
find a niche
like find a mode of being in which you
can show up
and like if you can find that
I think like
ambition is really just like how fast
you want to go at that point or like how
much like Leverage you want to implement
into your life
I tend to like to go slower
um I find like super scale or super
large ambition pretty scary
um and maybe that will change over time
but I have the mode so I have this like
deep faith that like I'm gonna be okay
and I also just like my life
and
but to someone looking at my life on a
spreadsheet and trying to like
do the math of like how life should be
live they'd be like how's this going to
work how are we going to afford a house
like I can't afford a house right now
is fine though because like that's not
what I'm valuing right now and I feel
really good about my life and I don't
feel like I'm failing
do you feel like
if and when you have kids that your
attitude towards this sort of stuff will
change
I think
so we want to have kids
um soon
and
I assume my perspective on a lot of
things will change in ways I can't
predict it
um
however I think it will just
force me to be more like committed
to like the things I'm doing I think
I've like we've already started to think
and talk about kids so like I do want to
be a parent and like a lot of what I've
been doing on this path has been
preparing myself to be a parent because
I want to be a present engaged and a
live parent
and that is just really important for me
so like this kind of life gives me the
highest odds of doing that yeah
but this is also why I've been like
leaning into like okay maybe I should
like try to like monetize some of the
things I'm doing
because I also realize like when I do
have kids I am going to feel more
responsible and that's just gonna make
me braver at this point probably and
also people are going to want to root
for me to succeed too
so like there's going to be benefits too
people sort of look at these things like
what about kids like what they're doing
is like mapping their fears onto me
um I already have those fears I have all
the fears on an uncertain path you
grapple with the fears every day
but I can make choices and I feel really
good about having ownership of the
degrees of freedom I have
and after five years I do see paths to
make money
so like if that was my Prime aim and I
have confidence I probably could do it
at this point
or I'll just apply for a job on your
team
yeah absolutely yeah welcome anytime
um Paul this has been absolutely
fantastic thank you so much for for
coming on the podcast uh where can
people learn more about you
and you're welcome uh so my newsletter
boundless.substack.com or website
think-boundless.com
um a lot of the ideas we talked about
are better put in my book uh the pathos
path uh check it out
um pretty active on Twitter too
um love hearing from people's stories so
uh definitely reach out
amazing and yeah just wanted to say a
massive thank you to you as well for
like all of the stuff that you've
written uh in the book and in the
newsletter that's and and on Twitter as
well and in podcasts that has continued
to inspire me over the last couple of
years as I've gone on to more of this uh
non-traditional more uncertain path than
the very traditional one that I was on
and yeah anyone listening to this if you
are considering breaking away from say
breaking away uh from a traditional path
and you would like some advice on how to
pursue an uncertain one yeah check out
all the pool stuff I was just looking
through my Kindle highlights on your
book and it's absolutely enormous and
yeah at some point I've been thinking I
need to get around to actually turning
turning a book into a book club video
for my channel but it's just the
incredible like copious amount of
highlights I have for him just like damn
it's okay this is going to be like a
whole like week-long project to just try
and parse all the stuff figure out what
are the bits that most resonated with me
because I find that when I'm when I'm
reading a book and I'm just enjoying all
of it highlight and then I'm like oh
damn highlighted like 80 of this book
damn that's kind of annoying I need to
go back through and progressively
summarize the highlights as some people
would recommend
awesome both continue to be inspired by
your journey too keep keep going man
thanks very much
um everyone Thanks for tuning in and
we'll catch you later bye-bye alright so
that's it for this week's episode of
Deep dive thank you so much for watching
or listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye